[Music]
so I suspect since you live here in LA
that you're friends with probably a lot
of completely secular non-believers who
may not even you may not even know
they're non-believers so what's the part
that I'm missing I consider myself
totally secular I try to live by some
sense of morality and whatever and like
everyone else I fail at it sometimes but
what's the peace that you can't stay on
on the good path so to speak without
religion well there are many there are
many well I mean why can't wait you know
that I'd be good to my neighbor and I'm
definitely there's no partner and those
type of the let me say is like a million
times this is really critical yeah if
there's no god there's no good and evil
there are only opinions about good and
evil having said that there are they're
a wonderful atheists and agnostics and
seculars and they were terrible
religiously I know that yeah but if you
want the long-term survival of a good
society it cannot be done without God it
will it will be an utter failure and and
the failure in Europe Europe is a
failing society it because it doesn't
stand up for anything it stands for
nothing Europe stands for nothing except
for feeling good about its own morality
for its socialism for you know what will
take care of the of everybody with a
safety net that we can't pay for so
bring in millions of Muslims who will
Adi Christian eyes and D westernized
society and there will be no Europe in
2040 years that's what's happening
America actually cares about retaining
the judeo-christian Basie's because it
knows what what George Washington said
in his in its farewell address or so or
was it the second inaugural know second
inaugural is is Lincoln but what he said
gets the farewell address anybody who
thinks that you can have a survival of
morality without religion it is thinking
foolishly and this guy was no
fundamentalist but but they the founders
understood no god no Liberty no god no
small government no
god no good and evil so yes the people
like you I have no doubt that you're a
good pup put up a little outline I don't
even have a little doubt I think you you
strike me as for a whole host of reasons
a very decent
an enquiring mind and so on I know that
exists but you are the product of the
judeo-christian system that you no
longer hold by so my question to you is
what's going to pass this on to
generation after generation and it's not
being passed the vast majority of kids
today indeed for the last 25 30 years
would save their dog before a human
because they love their dog and they
don't love the stranger they say it they
proudly announce I would save my dog
because we don't have objective morality
which says man is created in God's image
dogs or not we have subjective morality
what do you love I love my dog
so this mutt must put you in a strange
position with Trump though because I
think out of all of the Republicans that
you could have chosen right you
certainly could have said Ted Cruz you
surely could have said Marco Rubio said
you probably he probably Larry Royce but
he but he's the only one who could have
defeated the left so so that concept of
defeating that that even superseded
which supersedes everything right now
the left is show me allistic of force in
the world that it almost anything
supersedes it I mean there was a level
of evil but I wouldn't vote for
obviously to even to defeat the left
right but but there was no such living
Republican right so for let's say a
longtime fan of yours I'm sure you got
emails like this that said all right I
know Prager he's he's moral and he's
decent and all of these things he's
voting for a guy are now supporting what
I've got a lot he's now supporting a guy
who will say anything he wants tweet all
this crazy up is a narcissist I don't
know what is moral centuries I mean
that's what I kept saying the entire
time is I just don't know what the guy's
moral country I think there's a chance
where things are going to be great right
I didn't know was moral so that's why it
had there were two doors yeah man-eating
lion you have to the Democrat may be a
man-eating
and that's Trump so between maybe and
definite of course I'll vote for maybe
right
so then is this just a completely unique
political situation like is there
anything in your life that you can
remember that was I think there was an
article in one of the major papers today
I'm off as The Times or The Wall Street
Journal but one of them about the
uniqueness this is a whole new episode
it was like Jackson Andrew Jackson
transformed the country
FDR transformed the country this might
be one of those transformative moments
it might be the end of the least one of
the parties as we know it there are a
host of things that can happen yeah I
don't know what will happen I do know
this though that and I say this to the
Conservatives who call in and are still
sort of never Trump errs I said if
somebody would have given you his
cabinet list a year ago and said we
don't know who the nominee will be but
this will be the cabinet why would you
have said and they would have said we
would have been ecstatic right so
ironically he ended up going more
conservative in a direct in his cabinet
than he ran on that's true he's got the
truck you've got the Trump people the
manga people are anointed him about the
cabinet and the Conservatives are going
well I don't know if the Trump people
around or well because I think there's a
sense that maybe it's a little more no
well they know that little powers or the
people who were not conservative who
voted for him don't care who he points
the cabinet they care whether he
improves the economy do you think
there's a danger in just the way the
cult of personality around him that we
have a leader that it really is
superseding logic and reason even if you
end up liking some of the things any
lower some taxes and we don't getting
crazy military things even just that
that cult of per day now we certainly
had it with Obama too well that's what
my daddy when should my question yes I
answered my question yeah you were in
your question that's well sir yes it'll
be very difficult to match the amount of
cult enos around Obama so the change
this is what I mentioned that the at the
top of the show before you sat down at
the the change Obama came in at hope and
change in a certain respect there wasn't
a lot of change he did some things all
he Blake changed so what are some of the
things that he well he really he changed
you know what percentage of the
ami is health and he changed that to
move toward a 1 a 1 payer economy that
was a huge change I think he I think
everything he changed I think he did
he changed America's role in the world
to be a coming a bystander you know uh
Assad there's a red line in Syria if you
use chemical biological weapons so he
uses those weapons nothing happens so
it's a green light - we ran do whatever
you want in Syria Russia takes over
Crimea gee that's really unfortunate but
I still won't arm the Ukrainian
government so he is back down in every
instance than the agreement with Iran
the only government in the world that is
an announced that wishes to commit
genocide I mean that meant pretty pretty
significant and and court there's a
great Thom Munich phrase those who are
kind to the cruel will be cruel to the
kind so the nicer he got to Iran and
unlike Maya and Castro the tougher v
Gaudin Netanyahu so this is classic as a
rule of history
- 2000 year rules from the Talmud those
who were kind to the cruel be cruel to
the kind o Bhama and the left perfectly
encapsulate that vision so I suspect I
know your answer to this but going to
Israel for just a second you're a big
defender of Israel I saw your I think
you did a video before Prager you about
Israel did you say no no without that
that was pretty that was ok so that was
even before I do about I was a viral one
yeah yeah where you gave I thought a
very thoughtful historically accurate
version of what the truth is and and you
know the big line I think well let you
say that the end line basically one
table that the other side did and the
line yeah oh yeah the end line was yes
if tomorrow is real announced we are
fighting no more we are disbanding our
army we are just dismantling our
armaments what would happen that the
next day and if the Arabs announced you
know we are laying down our arms we are
fighting Israel no more what would
happen the next day in that scenario
well in the first scenario there would
be genocide Israel Israelis would be
wiped out they would
mass murder torture and rape in the
streets of Israel the on the other
scenario there would be peace within a
week yeah so I basically agree with that
so what is the obsession with Israel I
mean as I pointed out the day of their
you're carrying the world yeah the
obsession as I point out the day of the
carry speech I posted an image of the
entire Middle East with one little
orange sliver yeah amongst all of the
other guys right and this thing is tiny
you're talking about at one point I
think including the West Bank nine miles
wide at one point you know you could
have rocket they have one International
Airport in one place where gays and
atheists and Christians and the hi and
all of these people it's the only place
where you can see an Orthodox Jewish man
on a bus sitting next to a woman in a
hijab I mean it's the one place of
coexistence and they're obsessed with it
that's for and this is where I feel like
I've completely lost left I have tried
desperately to to bring some priority to
this and I don't know that I can what an
obsession what well in the final
analysis you have really hit my one of
my deepest beliefs in life and it's a
religious belief Jew hatred and Israel
hatred is Jew hatred not criticism of
Israel
nobody ever no one has ever said if you
criticize is really an anti-semite but
if you support those who wish to destroy
Israel whether you feel that you're a
Jew hater or not is irrelevant if you
say I want Italy destroyed you can say
I'm not anti Italian right okay so why
all the 200 plus countries on earth is
only one targeted for destruction and by
sheer coincidence it's the only Jewish
country in the world why of all the
people in the world has only one bit
targeted for true genocide we speak
genocide here genocide their genocide
everywhere but the one true genocide
take every baby every child every
grandparent who is a Jew and gas them
slaughter them shoot them bury them only
Jews Jew hatred is the owner or a book
on this called why the Jews Jew hatred
is the only hatred that is extermination
list that's very important
why to hated blacks did not wish to
exterminate all blacks you name and it's
a terrible hatred it's not a defense of
it but there is no other there is a
desire to wipe out the Jews and the
desire to wipe out Israel is part of the
desire to wipe out the Jews and it is it
is it is a a reason that I believe in
the truth ultimately of the biblical
narrative especially the first five
books the Torah that that when God chose
the Jews this chosen Isleta to be the
world hated people because they ended up
the conscience of the world so is the
irony that I think if you took I think
you've talked about this I'm sure you've
talked about this and I think we're
going on your book actually that if you
took most Jews in America they're
totally secular right they've sorted I
think I'm most are totally leftist right
and so I think that my hero is Trey said
a tree he says they traded their
religiosity for left is right in this I
think Ben Shapiro oh yeah Ryan does yeah
I've been saying it and spends it yeah
but not oh that's probably blame bother
yet where that war baby was born yeah
but that is but that is exactly right
and Ben is right and whoever says it is
right
the Jews Jew Jews what I saw the way I
put it is Jews are two isms what
Italians are the opera's if Jews think
about it every ISM Jews either created
or led mm-hmm except for Nazis right so
how do I have the time in ISM humanism
social capital is it happened cat well
not yet all right fine effect but that's
not an ideology that's just an economic
way you know environmentalism feminism
betty Friedan you know you name it
Trotsky you know three of the possible
successors to Lenin at Paula's death
three of the five there were only five
people three of the three of them Common
Era synovium in Trotsky would choose
Booker image Stalin were not Jewish so
in an odd way the why aren't you making
an argument against religion here
because if the idea is that well this
was the chosen group and look what you
know as what the name is Ted
I said in Fiddler on the Roof I was
chosen for da house right
well isn't that actually an argument
against religion because the Jews were
sort of set up whether it whether it's
divine or manly that there was a set up
that guess what you're going to be
exterminated and kicked across the world
and so if you would have asked me if you
would have Fida Bennett at Sinai and I
would have been told this is what's
going to happen to the Jews because
they're chosen I would have said to God
thanks but no thanks
have you been design a yes yeah you you
hack them out in an economic yeah yeah
did you have any religious all I'm not I
that's not the stuff I am moved by the
text more than I am by any physical
place so but I'm a typical in that way I
don't get all that choked up at any
monument or stuff like that yeah all
right so one more thing on this and
we'll move to a couple other issues what
do you think about also that the the
story has been lost here what the actual
history of the land is that's another
thing that I try to explain to people
that you know you talk about the
partition plan you talk about the fact
that you would Riddick you don't buy
that it was actually part of the Ottoman
Empire before that there were no people
called the Palestinian people it's right
people will say you're racist or there
were Arabs there in a way yeah notice
how sign that there were also Jews a
Palestinian in 1930 the people known as
Palestinians were the Jews yeah and they
were Boyka I mean you can look at New
York Times articles where the Arabs were
boycotting Palestine could ever do so
all of this stuff even when I say I feel
like I'm already unleashing a torrent of
hate royally but how do you beat people
that won't accept history how do you
there is not only a minute is it all
honesty there really is no way what we
have what my my dream with Prager
University let's say or my radio show or
anything that I do publicly is to say
what is true and I know that a certain
percentage of people will say wow I
didn't know that mm-hmm whereas the
majority will say oh you are a and call
you a bad name and that's that's what so
you can only hope that the number of
people who will say oh I didn't know
that
I'm going to change my mind is greater
than you imagined it would be
now that's the only hope but but it's
dispiriting that facts don't matter
hey Hitler said Jesus was an Aryan not a
Jew and the Palestinians say he was a
Palestinian not a Jew ok the the idea is
it's beyond lie yeah it's a new realm
yeah and so do you think we're post
truth now that seems to be the new mean
well yeah we yes we say truth is coming
from the enemies of Western liberalism
it's not coming from the right who is
protecting Western liberalism it's
coming from the left and from the
Islamists that's the irony
so let's critique the right a little bit
you've got to add some critiques at the
right right I don't have that many
critics give me that they don't know
about it and they don't know how to
fight all right so then no no they they
they don't they don't they don't know
what they stands they forgot it's like
it's like the choir forgot its melodies
but by and large I have to say and I
never thought I would have said this as
a kid you know growing up as a you know
a Jew in New York but the people on the
right that I have met of course there
are exceptions could they're disgusting
people on the right and they're
beautiful people on the left but by and
large the people on the right that I
have met have been kind and decent and
loving and you know they give more
charity they adopt more kids from I I
don't mean just general adoption that's
left and right but they adopt I was just
with the right wing guy who he and his
wife had two biological children and
then they adopted two more children from
China not newborns kids with terrible
illnesses hmm that is overwhelmingly
done by religious Christians in America
it's not done by Europeans it's not done
by secular in America of course I know
like their exceptions yeah well let's
get tiring having to say that all the
time I feel the same way to believe it
drives me crazy because then you know
you see yourself quoted and no you show
you have to make you know it's like
clarification for the foolish what but
in any event I've just been touched by
the homage you I have been overwhelmed
by the kindness of so many evangelical
Christians
[Music]
you